290 c'est le nombre de morts à cause des
volcans ses 500 dernières années
aujourd'hui pourtant on n'entend plus
parler de bilan humain aussi lourd des
irruptions cataclysmique comme celle des
dinosaures nous paraissent impossibles
comme si les volcans s'était affaibli
avec le temps et bien l'humanité va
payer très cher cette assurance car
sommeil en dessous de nos pièces parmi
les volcans les plus violents de
l'histoire des volcans qui pourrait nous
offrir le spectacle qu'ont vu les
derniers t-rex où se trouve-t-il sur la
carte qu'elle est l'éminence de leurs
menaces au vous dit tout sur les
supervolcans du futur quelle a été la
plus puissante éruption connu par
l'humanité d'après vous comment calcule
la puissance d'une éruption volcanique
peut pas vraiment m 2 sont au dessus des
cratères et espérer mesurer le souffle
de chaque explosion
c'est pour ça que les scientifiques ont
créé l échelle v e yves organique
explosivité in d'aix qui regroupe
plusieurs critères comme le volume de
matière éjectée ou la hauteur du nuage
de cendres pour estimer la puissance
relative il y a huit niveaux allant de
modéré à apocalyptique
chaque niveau multiplie sa puissance par
dix une explosion de rang 4 et 10 fois
plus puissante qu'une rang 300 fois plus
qu'une rang 2 et mille fois plus qu'une
rang 1
vous comprenez la logique vous voyez
pour pays cette ville mythique rasé par
les cendres des dizaines de milliers de
morts bah c'est juste un niveau 5 le
mont pelé en martinique considéré comme
l'éruption la plus meurtrière du xxème
siècle bien ce n'était qu'un niveau 4
est ce que l'humanité a déjà connu une
éruption stade v8 ultime pourrait
répondre faut que je vous parle de super
volcan et commence par l'éruption du
krakatoa on est sur une île en indonésie
le 26 août 1883 il ya du coup qu'en
dehors plein de grosses explosions
pendant plus de cinq heures il faisait
jour
maintenant il fait nuit un immense nuage
de cendres bloc le soleil bon c'est le
volcan - qui fait des siennes
mais nous là bas on est tranquilles ou à
la maison à plusieurs kilomètres de là
vous vous endormez l'esprit tranquille
pensant que le pire est passé
grave erreur car le lendemain aux
alentours de 10 heures
vous entendrez sûrement pour la dernière
fois le
volcan pétards de 200 mégatonnes niveau
puissance ces dix mille fois supérieur à
la bombe d'hiroshima et son nom de choc
a fait quatre fois le tour de la terre
le bruit des si fort qu'il a été entendu
par plus d'un dixième de la planète
le truc le plus fou c'est que ce bruit a
été enregistré l'un des plus vieux
enregistrements audio de l'humanité et
là des bruits les plus forts jamais
produit sur votre petit il donc vous
avez les tympans percés
vous êtes en vie ouais pas pour
longtemps car bientôt déferlera sur vous
les tsunamis de 40 mètres de haut qui
vont engloutir toutes les régions
côtières du pays résultat trente six
mille quatre cent dix sept morts et des
îles
rayés de la carte vous pensez sûrement
que je viens de vous raconter l'histoire
d'un volcan extrêmement puissant
toujours pas sur l'échelle de v8 ce
monstre n'était qu'au niveau 6 plus
récemment à un niveau 6 a explosé pas
très loin d'ailleurs un aux philippines
avec le pinatubo en 1991
des images terrifiantes et pourtant ils
étaient bien moins puissants que le
krakatoa alors passons au niveau
supérieur au niveau 7
pour ça il faut revenir en indonésie en
1815 avec la plus puissante explosion de
l'histoire
l'éruption du mont tambora c'est
l'éruption la plus dévastatrice qui soit
surtout les humains tué par un volcan un
tiers le sont à cause du mont tambora 88
morts
toute vie sur l'île a été entièrement
rayée de la carte
mais le plus grand danger ici ça a été
les 400 millions de tonnes de fumée qui
ont été projetés jusqu'à la mésosphère
soit bien plus aucune volent les avions
des particules qui vont ensuite rester
en suspension dans l'atmosphère pendant
des mois voire des années conséquence la
chimie du ciel change les pluies
deviennent acides les rayons du soleil
sont bloqués et l'agriculture mondiale
et ravagé la température mondiale a
chuté de 3 degrés cette année là un
véritable hiver volcanique ça a marqué
jusque dans les tableaux dans cette
peinture de william turner ce ciel
coloré d'orange de rouge et de pourpre
c'est pas un effet de style c'est le
ciel après tambora de l'indonésie jusqu
en europe pour certains ce serait même à
cause de tamboura que napoléon aurait
perdu la bataille de waterloo dépassé
par un climat devenu chaotique
ces cinq mille dernières années il n'ya
que sept autres éruptions de niveau 7
mais est ce que l'humanité a déjà connu
des mines
8 peut-être mais il faut remonter
beaucoup plus loin en pleine crise toi
il y à 70 mille ans cette éruption qui a
failli éradiquer l'humanité
oui l'humanité a failli disparaître à
cause d'un volcan et ça se passe encore
en indonésie
cette fois ci on est un homme
préhistorique donc plus de cabanes en
bois
ce volcan c'est le taux bas et crs se
retrouve aujourd'hui sur l'île de
sumatra
on ne sait pas grand chose de ce volcan
on ne peut donc pas en estimer la
puissance par rapport aux dégâts qu'il a
produit géologiquement il a injecté 3000
kilomètres cubes de roches et de cendres
l'explosion s'est élevé tellement haut
dans le ciel qu'on a découvert les
restes d'une pluie de verre des
fragments deux bagues maquis ont quasi
atteint l'espace et qui en gelée en
plein vol comme pour le mont tambora ces
particules en haute altitude ont eu des
effets catastrophiques avec des baisses
de température jusqu'à -15 degrés dans
les zones tempérées et pas pendant
quelques jours pendant six à dix ans et
tout ça suivi d'un refroidissement
global ces tendances sur un millénaire
fallait pour nos ancêtres de bonnes
grosses doudounes en peaux d'animaux
conséquences moins de plantes donc moins
d'animaux donc beaucoup moins de
nourriture comment a t'on survécu à sa
base justement on n'a pas si bien
résisté
pour certains chercheurs la catastrophe
de touba aurait été responsable de
l'extinction des premières race d'hommes
seuls une poignée quelques milliers
auraient survécu en afrique orientale
pour d'autres chercheurs des foyers
humains ont résisté un peu partout à
travers le monde
répondre à cette question est important
car elle permettrait de dater le moment
où l'humanité a eu la diversité qu'on
lui connaît aujourd'hui
quelle a été la plus puissante éruption
jamais connu sur terre pendant longtemps
on ne savait pas comment s'était
terminée le règne des dinosaures
plusieurs théories s'affrontent et la
thèse de l'astéroïde et la thèse du
volcanisme
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que les deux ont eu lieu en
même temps l'impact de l'astéroïde tombé
au mexique aurait induit une énorme
ondes sismiques fragilisant la croûte
terrestre à l'antipode de l'impact se
réveillait alors les trappes des camps
aujourd'hui on trouve les vestiges de
ces volcans en inde
mais ça c'est à cause du mouvement des
plaques continentales en réalité le
point chaud qui a ravagé les dinosaures
se trouve aujourd'hui sous l'île de la
réunion
en france vous vous en doutez les
trappes de des camps n'ont pas été les
seuls hyper volcan de cette époque
l'éruption de la caritat il ya environ
26 millions d'années est considérée
comme la plus puissante éruption que la
terre n'est
méconnue pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée c'est équivalent à 12 millions
500 mille bombes nucléaires
si on veut des volcans encore plus
monstrueux il faut changer de planète
le mont olympe sur mars par exemple
s'élève à plus de 22 mille mètres quatre
fois la hauteur de l'everest sur la lune
yacht jupiter les éruptions sont si
violentes qu'on les voit depuis l'espace
ça c'est un volcan normal ça c'est un
bord à sa sega rita et ça c'est les
volcans diot les volcans sont ils encore
dangereux aujourd'hui en un mot oui 600
millions de personnes vivent sous la
menace d'un volcan actif 6 % de la
population même en europe en islande ou
en italie les volcans tue encore
regarder ces touristes fuyant l'éruption
de stromboli en moyenne à l'échelle de
la terre il y à 80 éruption chaque année
heureusement 97% d'entre elles sont en
dessous du niveau 5
on estime néanmoins qu à votre corps de
niveau 7 explose tous les 500 ans et un
niveau 8 tous les cinquante mille ans en
1983 une petite fissure dans un champ de
maïs au mexique va se transformer en
quelques jours seulement en un volcan de
130 mètres de hauteur crash en fumée et
magma pendant neuf ans
la prochaine fois que tu vois une
fissure dans ton jardin rappelle toi de
ce volcan on ne sait jamais heureusement
la plupart des volcans qui naissent et
qui explosent ne présente aucun danger
pour nous pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'ils sont sous la mer 1,5 million
c'est le nombre de volcans sous-marins
mille fois plus de volcans sous la mer
que sur terre et elles sont plutôt de
schille un bateau qui passerait
au-dessus d'un super volcan sous marin
ne verrez pas qu'une eau de mer
ressemblant un jacuzzi
des poissons morts sur 5 km et enfin une
odeur de soufre infâme tout ce qu'on
peut souhaiter à l'humanité c'est que le
prochain volcan de niveau 8 qui
explosera se passera sous l'eau
malheureusement ça ne sera pas le cas la
plus grande menace pour l'humanité se
trouve bien sur terre yellow stone le
volcan qui détruira l'occident cet
américain qui visitent tranquillement
les sources d'eau chaude ne se doute de
rien il est pourtant quelques dizaines
de kilomètres au dessus de la proue
grandes chambres bachmann
du monde 45 km de large et 85 de
longueur rien que ça la chaleur dans
cette chambre s'accumulent il y a bien
quelques chaises est requis pour le
plaisir des touristes mais ça ne suffit
pas pour toutes évacuées
combien de temps les roches de
yellowstone ont-elles supporter la
pression et la température exercée par
le magma
ce qui inquiète plus avec qui et le
stone c'est que les volcans ont des
cycles et actifs c'est-à-dire qu'ils
explosent plus ou moins sur les mêmes
intervalles de temps pour les éruptions
de niveau 8 juillet au stade ses
environs t'oublies 600 mille ans la
dernière a eu lieu il ya 640 me leurre
pas du tout rassurant
voilà pourquoi la nasa étudie des
solutions pour refroidir le volcan enfin
de réduire le risque
une de leurs idées seraient par exemple
de creuser un tunnel et d'y introduire
de l'eau sous haute pression qui chauffé
par le volcan au monde sous forme de
vapeur vapeur utilisa pour produire de
l'énergie et engranger des profits on
est aux états unis je vous rappelle
néanmoins cette solution n'est pas sans
risque et pourraient entraîner les faits
totalement inverse en fragilisant le
milieu et en accélérant la venue de la
super éruption que se passerait-il alors
si le yellowstone explosé et bien images
nous que ce soit aujourd'hui
histoire de finir 2020 en beauté tout
souvient de l'américain dans sa source
d'eau chaude
j'espère qu'il court vite et l'éruption
sera tellement violent qu elle ralliera
totalement de la carte les 150 km autour
du volcan
avec des nuées ardentes de 500 degrés
lancé à plus de 400 kilomètres heure
rien ne survivra yao ming montana idaho
déjà plusieurs millions d'habitants tous
grillées à point
un énorme nuage de cendres surgira des
centrales de la terre elle recouvrira
sous plusieurs centimètres de cendres la
quasi-totalité des usa deux tiers des
états unis seraient rendues inhabitables
dû à la toxicité des gaz
on parle de 100 millions d'américains
dont la vie serait détruite
et comme s'ils s'étaient passés les
cendres dans l'atmosphère vont se
disperser aux quatre coins du monde
provoquant un hivers volcaniques au
moins aussi long que celui de touba
l'être humain sera-t-il alors capable de
survivre dans ces conditions
probablement mais les conséquences sur
l'économie mondiale seront massives
famine il
ration épidémies et j'en passe un livre
d'histoire retiendront comment
l'hégémonie américaine est tombée pour
toujours
[Musique]
on